nous retrouvons le docteur car le vice
président de l'association du médecin
microbiologiste et infectiologue du
québec
bonsoir dr weiss j'allais bien vous ça
va occuper ça va bon la santé va bien tu
es bien le québec en pause
est-ce que c'est injustifié selon vous
là où tout à fait parce que regarder ce
qui se passe ailleurs dans le monde vous
avez on est à face à quelque chose
il n'y a pas de demi mesures ou bien on
fait tout et on va à l'extrême jusqu'à
un certain point
ou bien on va se retrouver avec une
vague quand mon avis ailleurs et il ya
des différences pour contrer emparé
capter des choses qui sont génétiques
qu'il ya des populations plus
susceptibles que d'autres etc
mais si on ne met pas tous les moyens en
place pour essayer de casser cette cette
bague qui s'en vient c'est sûr qu'on va
se retrouver dans un scénario qui risque
d'être inimaginable au québec il ya
seulement trois mois
comment vous jugez la progression de la
conca nahd yens de la courbe québécois
justement si on compare avec le pire
c'est-à-dire l'italie regardez on a eu
une augmentation importante au québec
mais il y avait un certain délai avec
les tests dont il ya beaucoup de tests
qui sont sortis aujourd'hui mais qui
étaient ils étaient attendus dont il le
nombre a augmenté de façon très
considérable mais c'est le reflet de
plusieurs jours par contre on sait qu'on
est dans une accélération de notre phase
de la cour et c'est vraiment à ce moment
là qu'on va devoir commencer à avoir
tout le système au grand complet qui va
devoir mettre la main à la pâte
il faut savoir aussi que les gens
malades qui ne sont pas testés
je le sais j'ai des patients sont
malades ou v positif mais on n'a pas
testé le conjoint ou la conjointe les
enfants les etc et les patients nous
disent oui j'ai des gens malades autour
de moi et c'est clairement une maladie
affectueux coronavirus 19 donc tout ce
que je veux dire c'est que le nombre de
cas augmente dans la communauté
c'est clair mais si on n'est pas là
je dirai à la roue et que ce soit un
effort coordonné c'est clair qu'on va se
retrouver dans une situation difficile
donc le nombre de cas va augmenter il va
augmenter de façon plus significative
potentiellement dans les prochains jours
le président américain a dit aujourd'hui
il faut pas que le remède derrière ça ça
crée beaucoup de confusion
il ne faut pas que le remède c'est à
dire paralyser l'économie soit pire que
le mal
qu'est ce que vous répondez au président
américain dr weiss ce que vous en pensez
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
regarder on est dans une situation qui
est inédite
on est finalement victime de nous même
jusqu'à un certain point c'est-à-dire
pour penser que les études techniques
ont donc on parlait dans des ligues
d'histoire invite également disparu et
voilà temps plein xxième siècle avec
toute ma technologie on se fait frapper
par quelque chose notre société n'était
pas préparée et la seule façon de
contenir sein dans l'état actuel des
choses c'est de vraiment casser la
transmission cassé les chaînes de
transmission et si on veut pas avoir un
nombre élevé de décès on n'a pas d'autre
choix que de limiter la transmission de
ce virus là donc oui c'est c'est c'est
impensable je pense pour des
gouvernements occidentaux de se
retrouver dans la situation dans
laquelle ils se trouvent actuellement
mais c'est quelque chose qui était déjà
prédit qui a été discuté dans le passé
et les gouvernements avaient eu un avant
goût avec le h1n1 et quand les gens
parler de pandémie
je pense que les gens sont parfois
prenez ça un petit peu à la légère et
penser que ça ne pouvait pas arriver que
notre société moderne technologique ne
pouvait pas avoir ce genre de choses là
mais il est clair que on n'a pas le
choix aujourd'hui de passer au travers
avec des mesures qui sont drastiques et
auquel la société du xxième siècle n'est
pas habitué
très bien je vous donne quelques
questions du public dr weiss si j' ai
testé positif aux corvées 19 et que je
guéris puis je me considérais immunisés
où je pourrai attrapé le virus une
deuxième fois
alors on va considérer ces gens-là
immunisés en fait c'est pour ça que moi
je pense que je le fais d'ailleurs que
tous les travailleurs de la santé qui
tombent malades dont les tests parce
qu'on sait que les travailleurs de la
santé qui sont malades
positifs et qu'ils vont guérir vont être
d'excellents ap
après ça support pour le système opus
comment s'occuper des gens malades
sachant que le risque aurait attrapé une
infection et ce sera à ce moment là
quasiment nue donc pour un certainement
pour les prochaines années vont être ils
vont être entre guillemets protéger ce
genre là très bien y at il des séquelles
observé chez les gens atteints de la
coved 19 et qui sont guéris alors et les
gens qui ont été intubé qui ont des
problèmes de maladie sévère en faire de
la fibrose pulmonaire
ça a été bien décrit dans en europe et
en chine dans les gens qui sont passés
avant nous donc c'est finalement c'est
comme une coupure imaginer c'est une
grosse coupure sur la peau et que vous
avez vous allez avoir une cicatrice qui
va qui va arriver c'est la même chose
vous allez rester avec une cicatrice
surprenant il va rester de la fibrose
pas chez tout le monde
mais j'ai des gens qui auraient été des
très sévèrement mais là le message n'est
pas clair pour certaines personnes pour
se rendre à une clinique sans rendez
vous la vie une vient d'ouvrir au
centre-ville de montréal y aller si on
revienne voyage avec ou sans symptômes
bah écoutez je pense que d'abord ce
qu'on veut pas ces gens totalement non
malades asymptomatiques se fasse tester
et là vous comprendre au niveau de la
population que c'est important qu'on
teste les gens qui sont malades les gens
qui sont symptomatiques et que les gens
ne prennent pas ça juste pour aller se
faire passer un test en disant tiens je
vais vérifier si je n'ai pas on veut
surtout pas que ces gens-là aille là bas
parce que on va vous tester pour rien la
valeur du test n'est pas forcément très
bonne dans cette population là ça vous
donnera pas un gage de protection et
vous allez utiliser des ressources pour
pas grand chose donc les gens qui
doivent être testés si les gens qui sont
malades et qui ont des symptômes
voilà si on le répétera jamais assez
même si vous revenez de l'étranger vous
allez 14 jours chez vous mais j'ai pas
besoin d'aller vous faire tester
inutilement
si vous n'avez pas de pierre puis une
fièvre s'il est en hausse de 38 n'est ce
pas d'acteur tout à fait et si vous
n'avez pas de symptômes c'est sûr que si
vous tous et vous avez un mal de gorge
intense à la limite ou là le risque est
élevé vous avez été en contact avec
quelqu'un ça vaut la peine de se faire
tester et on le fait surtout dans
certaines catégories de gens parce que
par exemple les travailleurs de la santé
les gens qui au point de vue
épidémiologique pourrait avoir un impact
important
donc il ya certains groupes sera mais ce
qu'on veut pas que les gens qui soient
asymptomatiques se fasse d'esters et
s'il vous plaît message à la population
n'essayez pas de nous raconter que vous
êtes symptomatique alors que vous ne
l'êtes pas uniquement pour vous faire
tester
oui c'est un bon message à envoyer ne
mentez pas au contraire si vous avez de
la fièvre et c'était rebond suite au
point de presse aujourd'hui à dernières
questions du public docteur vas y fais
ce que je comprends qu'on ne peut plus
aller marcher seuls dans notre quartier
écoutez je n'ai pas écouté le point de
presse j'étais pris à voir des patients
et à l'idée si on indique qu' il fallait
essayer de garder la distanciation
social le plus possible ce qu'on ne veut
pas c'est qu'on ne veut pas avoir des
groupes d'adolescents et de jeunes
adultes comme on voit beaucoup se
promener ensemble
et finalement c'est peut-être pas la
meilleure chose à faire dans le contexte
actuel du slam donc de cette
distanciation sociale est importante et
il n'y a pas de chiffre magique c'est
vous savez le ministère initialement
avait dit de 105 ans mais les gens
avaient fait ça de façon très correcte
c'est pas 249 c'est correct et 251 c'est
mauvais ce qu'on veut pas c'est que les
gens s'agrègent en groupe et compte font
des activités ensemble avec de gros deux
questions avant de vous laisser docteur
1 comment se portent les gens autour de
vous dans l'ailé le personnel de la
santé il ya eu des craintes manifestées
aujourd'hui qu'ils avaient passé de
masse qu'on gardait les masses pour
certains endroits etc
comment les gens autour de vous ce porte
écoutez il ya beaucoup de travail à
faire c'est normal qu'une certaine peur
il faut vaincre cette peur là il faut
protéger les travailleurs de la santé il
faut aller au delà de la protection
qu'on demande
on n'a pas le choix que d'aller à la
guerre avec l'équipement qu'il nous faut
il va falloir utiliser des masques en
quantité faramineuse c'est l'expérience
qu'on a appris de france d'italie
d'espagne
moi j'ai parlé à des gens dans ces pays
là j'ai communiqué avec eux et le
message c'est que il faut essayer de
protéger les travailleurs de la santé le
plus possible en mettant l'équipement
maximale ya alors il faut vraiment le
faire ces efforts là j'espère aussi
qu'on n'aura pas de manque d'équipements
dans les semaines à venir il va falloir
le canada d
ce maître pendant tant de guerres à
produire de façon massive du matériel
médical et puis c'est une espèce de
parallèles qu'il faut faire quasiment
avec notre histoire dans le passé très
bien dr vince pour les zones question je
reviens de lyon se reparlera cette
semaine merci vous êtes très gentil
c'est très appréciée de nos
téléspectateurs des gens qui nous
suivent sur le web etc
merci à très bientôt dr weiss bonne
chance et le plaisir merci au revoir